so let's just say President Trump is
watching this and he knows there's
pressure on him pardoning you one on the
side of people who supports you and and
also on the other side of if they he
does pardon you he's gonna get a lot of
heat knowing re-elections coming up and
maybe Jared Kushner who is a little bit
more of a logical guy who doesn't
necessarily have maybe the relationship
that you have with Trump since 1988
maybe Jared whispers and says this is
not a good time to pardon maybe let's
pardon in December or January February
if they're watching this are you okay
with the pardoning not taking place
anytime soon till 2021
you know one of the first things I
learned in politics from Richard Nixon
don't answer hypothetical questions
here's what I know
Donald Trump is a person of great
fairness okay he's a great he's a he's a
person of great mercy and he knows
what's happened here but here's what I
also know nobody tells Donald Trump what
to do
not Roger stone not Jared Kushner not
certainly not Steve Ben and nobody and
therefore he'll make I believe that he
will make the right decision at the
right time and I pray to God that that
will be sooner rather than later
but I'm you know I'm not advocating
anything other than justice because I
think it is abundantly clear the
president has noted several times that I
did not get a fair trial when the jury
forewoman is attacking me in 2019 and
then she erases those posts to cover her
trail no reasonable lawyer believes that
that is correctly decided Jonathan
Turley is not a conservative or a
Republican he said stone isn't it is
entitled to a new trial on that basis in
the Boston Marathon bombing case the guy
convicted got a new trial because one of
his jurors was posting on social media
on the topic of terrorism not even that
case just the topic of terrorism my
juror had not a single Trump supporter
not a single Republican not a single
military veteran not a single
blue-collar worker not a single person
less than a college education but a
majority would post college education
three appointees from the Obama and
Clinton administration's several people
who had personal relationships at the
Department of Justice or the FBI it was
by no means a jury of my peers knowing
knowing how he's wired I wouldn't be
surprised if he just decided to pardon
you tomorrow
you know after all the messes going on
to have the media go crazy about the
fact that your pardon but let's just say
he does if he pardons you would you
agree to get a tattoo of Donald Trump
instead of Nixon on your back you know I
was thinking of doing Patrick you know
under stay to do it right I thought I
would add Trump Goldwater and Buckley to
my back to have kind of a Mount Rushmore
ugly Wow Buckley on their list is he's
one of a kind they don't have too many
Buckley's nowadays so so so that means
we should be expecting some new tattoos
here soon they say you can't just get
one tattoo on life but once you start
one there's a bunch that come afterwards
well from your mouth to God's ear
[Music]